(coin clinking)
- All the machines in
this arcade are homemade.
There's something magical about all this.
As a child, I found that
making things that made people
laugh was satisfying and seemed
more point in doing that
than making useful machines.
(whimsical music)
I'm Tim Hunkin, and I'm a
cartoonist and engineer.
I have two arcades, one
on the coast on the pier,
and this one in central London
called Novelty Automation.
In total, I suppose I've
made about 50 machines.
Not many people have that
as their ambition in life,
but yeah, it suits me.
This is Pet or Meat.
You spin the wheel, and you
find if the lamb ends up
sitting with you on the sofa,
or being carved for dinner.
It was a hobby that got out of control.
This is Autofrisk.
You stand in front here,
the gloves inflate,
and then they pat you down.
Britain's got a great history
of satire, and I suppose
I'm not really particularly
political myself, but I think
it's healthy for little people to poke fun
at the rich and powerful.
You fly this little drone round
this Beverly Hills mansion,
and see all the stars
inside, and you're paparazzi.
You have to try and take
the photos to fill up
the cover of the magazine.
- [Game] You're all under arrest.
(camera shutter clicks)
- I get my ideas from lots of places.
It's partly things happening
in my life, partly things
happening in the news, and
partly from old arcade machines
and mechanisms.
This is Test Your Nerve.
You have to put your hand
inside the cage with the mad dog
for as long as you dare.
(game growling)
To do something like this,
you have to enjoy the process
of making things.
I spent most of my life solving
conventional engineering
problems, rather than
thinking up the jokes.
(laughing)
This is the Chiropodist.
You have to take off
your shoe for this one.
You put your foot in the
treatment bay down the bottom,
and it feels really weird.
Seeing people enjoying, using
the machines, keeps me at it.
And also, because they
take money, it provides
me income to let me keep at it.
So to me, it's a pretty perfect system.
It sure beats working.
- [Game] Good morning, sir.
- I never planned my career
or anything about my life.
It's just occasionally a
sort of opportunity comes up,
and then I go for it. (laughing)
(munching sounds)